we've all heard about the importance of
iq in our interactions and some of us
have even heard about eq emotional
intelligence in our interactions but
have you heard of cq
cultural intelligence
today i am excited to explore how
culture influences our communication
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
i am really excited to chat with
michelle gelfand michelle is the john h
scully professor in cross-cultural
management and a professor of
organizational behavior she uses field
experimental computational and
neuroscience methods to understand
cross-cultural organizational behavior
negotiation conflict and diversity
michelle is the author of rulemakers
rule breakers how tight and loose
cultures wire the world
welcome michelle it's great to be here
matt thanks for being here and and a big
congratulations to you on your induction
to the national academies of science
that's so exciting thank you you are
known for many things but perhaps the
idea most associated with you and your
work is the idea of tight and loose
cultures i'd love to have you define
what you mean by those two concepts and
perhaps explain how the muppets fit into
all of this yeah so i'm a cross-cultural
psychologist and i study culture
which is really a puzzle you know it's
omnipresent it's all around us and it
affects us from the moment we wake up
until the time we go to sleep but we
take it for granted it's like the two
fish swimming around and they pass by
another fish who says hey boys how's the
water
and they swim past them they say what's
water right and that story indicates
something really profound which is that
sometimes the most important realities
around us are the most difficult to
appreciate or recognize and for fish
that's water but for humans that's
culture so i try to understand the
deeper cultural codes that drive our
behavior and i focus on social norms and
these are basically unwritten rules for
behavior that sometimes get more
formalized in terms of codes and laws
and in particular how strictly people
follow social norms as much has been my
focus you know the idea is that all
cultures have social norms you know we
drive on one side of the street versus
both sides of the street we don't
steal people's food and restaurants or
start singing in libraries most of us
don't do that because these are things
that help us coordinate our behavior
they're the glue that keeps us together
but some cultures have strict social
norms we call them tight cultures
other cultures have looser social norms
where there's more permissibility of
behavior and so we try to really
quantify how tight or loose our cultures
around the world um not just nations but
then we can zoom in and look at
states in the u.s or provinces in china
we can look being even beyond that in
terms of organizations how strict or
permissive tight or loose they are we
can even look into our own mindsets we
can classify people in terms of whether
they're an order muppet like bert or
whether they're a chaos muppet like
ernie or like cookie monster and the
idea is that we all are socialized for
certain mindsets whether tight or loose
and it's important to understand why
these codes develop why do they evolve
in the first place
what trade-offs do they provide for
people for organizations for nations
that's what really we try to do in
cross-cultural psychology is try to
understand these cultural codes quantify
them study them all around the world
it's totally fascinating i'm channeling
my inner elmo as i'm talking to you we
had phil zimbardo on a while ago and
phil was a mentor of mine when i was a
student here at stanford and we talked
about norms and the influence of how
they can impact our activities and
actions and it sounds like you're diving
very deep into that i'm curious is there
an advantage to having a tight or loose
culture is one better than the other
yeah this is such a great question and
you know we published a paper some years
ago in science where we ask people all
around the world about the level of norm
strength in their countries
and places like singapore and japan
china
austria germany they tended to lean
tighter even though all type cultures
have loose elements and all loose
cultures have tight elements they've
veered tight cultures like brazil greece
the netherlands the us they tended to
veer looser again even though all
cultures have both elements and what we
found is in general thai cultures held
out of order they have less crime
they have more monitoring in terms of
police per capita security cameras
they also have more synchrony so they
have people who are wearing more similar
clothing or driving more similar cars
more uniformity even city clocks in
streets have more synchrony in tight
cultures we actually measured this we
looked at how aligned are clocks in city
streets and actually in tight cultures
they're off by milliseconds
and in loose cultures you're not totally
sure what time it is like the clocks are
not synchronized right and also tight
cultures have a lot of order when it
comes to self-control so if you live in
a culture where
there's a lot of social order and
uniformity you learn to manage your
impulses from a very early age and that
has its downstream effects on things
like lower debt in tight cultures lower
obesity and lower alcoholism and drug
abuse so tech cultures corner the market
on order and loose cultures struggle
with order they have more crime less
monitoring less synchrony like the clock
example and they have a host of
self-regulation problems even by the way
animals like pets tend to be fatter in
loose cultures but loose cultures corner
the market on openness they have more
tolerance of people from different races
religions creeds
we actually even sent out our research
assistants to to do a field experiment
outside in their home countries where i
dressed them up with either facial warts
that i bought for them on the internet
like halloween sort of yeah you know we
kind of put lots of warts on their faces
uh in another condition they were
wearing like tattoos and nose rings and
purple hair
and in a third condition they were just
wearing the normal face and we simply
had them go ask for directions in city
streets or in stores in their home
countries and what we found was
fascinating on this kind of openness
issue we found that when people were
just wearing their normal face there was
no cultural differences in helping
behavior but when they were wearing
these strange
things on their face or tattoos and nose
rings they got far more help in looser
cultures so that's an indication of
tolerance out there in the wild we also
know that loose cultures corner of the
market on openness in terms of
creativity idea generation there's been
large-scale studies of creativity where
people from loose cultures are more
likely to enter those contests and more
likely to win and these cultures tend to
be more adaptable and new norms enter
the population they tend to sort of take
off more quickly so loose culture's
corner the market on openness and thai
cultures struggle with openness so in
that sense it's a trade-off we can
harness the power of social norms
to shift in either direction and and i
think that's really an important part of
the book and in our research is how do
you start pivoting when you get too
tight or too loose how do you try to
maximize order and openness so the
dialectic of order versus openness i
find really fascinating and i'm curious
for an individual is just recognizing it
the first step to being able to adjust
and adapt you know i live in a loose
culture and i look at my own household
where i might have a more loose attitude
than let's say my wife are those things
that can be changed over time the first
thing i would say is it's important to
understand one's own self and for that
you can go to my website at
michellegalfan.com and take the titus
mindset quiz this is actually based on
data that we published in science and
you can see where you score on this
continuum and i i want to emphasize we
can all kind of switch codes quite
easily like when you go to a library you
know your type mindset kind of kicks in
like you kind of know this is a tight
context i can't start doing all sorts of
weird things
right or in the classroom for the most
part and then when we're in a party or
in public parks we kind of become looser
so we can it's amazing actually how much
we can really rapidly switch codes with
that said we all have our own default on
the titles continuum based on our own
cultures our ethnicity our
race gender our occupations and so forth
michelle before we go on i'd love to
understand a little bit about the
evolution of tight and loose cultures it
has something to do with threat doesn't
it yes so what we wanted to understand
is why do titan loose cultures evolve
the way they do and what we found was
really interesting they didn't
vary in terms of their wealth like gdp
like so there's
loose cultures that are poor and rich
and tight cultures that are poor and
rich they're not different in terms of
religion or location but what we did
find is that one reliable predictor of
titles is the degree to which groups or
individuals or nations have experienced
a lot of chronic threat threat at the
national level can be either from mother
nature think like chronic natural
disasters or famine but it can also be
based on human threats like think about
how many potential times your nation's
been invaded over the last hundred years
and we selected these nations based on
how much they varied on chronic threat
as far back as 1 500. cultures that have
a lot of threat need stricter rules to
coordinate in order to survive and whose
cultures that have experienced less
threat could afford to be more
permissive tight cultures across the
board not all but many had much more
threat and we've validated this at the
state level in the u.s tight states in
the south and the midwest tend to have
more threats as well we can also see
this with an organizational context
organizations that lean tight are in
context where there's a lot of safety
issues coordination problems i want to
say no again not all type cultures have
threat and not all loose cultures are on
easy street but it's really an important
principle that threat
does seem to cause the evolution of
tightness
so threat really underlies a lot of that
and it might be interesting to analyze a
lot of what we see in terms of the
impact of threat in the history of
threat within organizations
relationships etc now those who listen
and know that language is something i've
always found very fascinating i love the
fact that you have looked into language
as well and in fact you published a
threat dictionary can you tell us a
little bit more about i've never seen a
threat dictionary before that's right so
this is a paper we just published
recently the idea is that we're
constantly being bombarded by
threatening information whether it's on
social media in the newspaper you know
um radio newscasts hopefully not this
podcast exactly we're talking a lot
about threat and you know it's something
that is really affecting our brain
circuitry and we wanted to develop
methods to track it
in real time so we partnered with some
computational linguistic scholars along
with psychologists myself and developed
a new threat dictionary that it's
developed based on big data we seeded
out words into different platforms like
twitter wikipedia common crawl and we
chose words that were coalescing around
each other that were clustering together
things like attack and crisis destroy
fear injury outbreak unrest these kinds
of words are
really tapping to the psychology of
threat and what we want to do is then
track threat over time over the last
hundred years with newspapers so all the
newspapers published in the us we
tracked threat whether it's changing
over time and we found for example that
during times of threat there were
far more ethnocentric types of attitudes
on other surveys against immigrants
there was more rallying around the flag
around current u.s presidents more
conservative shifts during threat we
found that norms tended to become
tighter during times of threat in
general people became more groupie more
collectivistic
we also found during times of threat
that economic activity took a big
toll in terms of the stock market it's
just a new dictionary that can help us
track threat and understand its
influence one other thing we found is
that threat talk is very contagious and
so you know when you add a threat word
or two to a tweet that really increases
its retweeting power
and this just suggests that we know when
we have these tools we can start
tracking in our own lives like how much
threat am i being exposed to what other
things does it predict whether it's like
how ceos talk about threat how does that
affect how other competitors see the
company or customers it can be used to
track online
radicalization a lot of times people are
using threat to tighten people elected
leaders use threat and manufacture
threat fake threat that tightens people
unnecessarily so there's ways that we
can now
make this very powerful psychology more
visible and more tangible and measurable
in real time and it can also help all of
us reflect on the language that we use
and maybe become more personally
responsible for the way in which we
use certain words yeah that's right and
on my website you the threat dictionary
is publicly available you can download
it you can have your own feed what kind
of threat talk do you see in your feed
what it will give you kind of a
breakdown of the words and so forth so
huh so this might be one of those things
that can help break those thought
bubbles that people talk about if we can
see literally
the types of language that we're
receiving called out would be really
interesting i find that work fascinating
the notion of a threat dictionary it
used to be my teachers would threaten
that i'd have to go read the dictionary
if i did something wrong and now now
there's a threat dictionary i'm excited
to read so thank you
i know michelle that you are very
interested and passionate about justice
and diversity equity and inclusion
what insights do you have based on your
research and other things that you've
done to
help us better
understand the issues and challenges and
perhaps do better in this space
yeah the most recent work that we're
doing on this topic is really around
tight loose the idea is that research
suggests that women and minorities tend
to live in tighter worlds so that's to
suggest that they are being evaluated
more harshly or more strictly with
consequences for deviance that a
majority high-powered groups don't don't
have and we can see that we've done some
studies for example in banks where we
ask
managers to evaluate deviant behavior by
just switching the name jamal or leticia
or brad or lauren and these are like
workplace deviant types of questions
around like coming to work late or being
on the phone or so forth other things or
even more major deviants and it was
remarkable to see that
there was no in-group effect it wasn't
that women and minorities were
evaluating each other more leniently for
these behaviors they didn't they didn't
actually differentiate who was doing the
behavior but white majorities tend to
let other majorities off the hook and
they were much more harsh on
a woman and minority so that suggests
that we need to start thinking about the
worlds we live in when it comes to
accountability and we're starting to do
more work on that in everyday life
through some experiential sampling daily
diary types of studies to understand the
constraints that women and minorities
and people from stigmatized identities
have to experience it seems to me that
people who are stigmatized and coming
from a represented minority are under
threat much more yeah yeah i mean we're
doing a lot more work now also on social
class this is like a hidden dimension of
diversity that we don't study so much um
we're building on some really great work
in psychology on social class that was
looking at collectivism and how family
oriented people are from working class
versus upper class but we can also look
at this from a tight loose lens and we
can see that
people who are in the working class they
have a lot more threat they have to
worry about falling into hard living
they have to worry about crime in their
neighborhoods they have to worry about
occupational hazards in the kind of jobs
they have they tend to lean tighter you
know you can think about all sorts of
mismatches when you have working-class
kids going to like predominantly loose
institutions like colleges right what
happens with that mismatch we've been
starting to study that and understanding
that we need to start thinking about
diversity in terms of these underlying
dimensions of culture interesting that's
that's fascinating the notion of class
and how it fits in before we end
i'd love to ask you the same three
questions i ask everyone are you up for
that yeah sure excellent
question number one if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you've ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title what would
that be
i think one of the things is really
important is to know your audience being
passionate and charismatic kind of
empowering i think is really important
but also being super clear
and so forth i think it's really
important to make your audience feel
like they're the only person in the room
you're just laser focused on that person
that requires a lot of listening skills
that requires also just pure like
attention
i just want everybody to notice that i
gave a very tight restriction and you
you blew away with a very open response
i so many things you said are really
important knowing your audience really
helping
give content that's relevant to them the
notion of making the person feel like
they're the only person in the room is
really powerful uh i'm curious for
question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
um here i am being loose again i have
two two answers all right
one is harry trandis i mean he was just
someone who was so brilliant in his
breadth of knowledge but he was not
someone who took himself so seriously he
was very humble so much putting himself
at the level of his audience and i
really admire that i was going to
nominate thomas friedman the new york
times journalist for that too i have
breakfast with him every so often and we
did a joint book talk when my book came
out and he's also someone who really
listens so well and he's so passionate
and so learning oriented that he just
wants to hear your perspective and he's
also brilliant and has so much knowledge
so we just when we meet for breakfast
we're both taking notes frantically you
know and i really admire how he operates
and learns about the world through
communication and listening i hate to
give you a constraint on this third
question but what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe
audience
passion
humility audience passion and humility
we've heard the first two before talk to
me a little bit about humility why is
that so important to you i think that
people are much more likely to listen to
you and understand you when you treat
them
with respect and when you
don't take yourself too seriously you
know that helps people to
feel
seen and understood and that's going to
open their minds more to what you have
to say thank you and thank you for being
here today that idea of opening minds to
what you have to say you've certainly
done that for us in a very
non-threatening way so thank you for
that and you make something that's so
important and serious very
applied you give us very specific
techniques and i for one am going to
re-look at how i interact with others so
thank you thank you for having me
[Music]
you've been listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business
this episode was produced by mike
o'reilly jenny luna and me matt abrahams
find more resources and join our
conversation
on linkedin by searching think fast talk
smart
please download and subscribe wherever
you get your podcasts
[Music]
you